once you do type stuff up
you use emacs yeah i use emacs obviously
the superior editor of course
you uh
let me just ask the ridiculous
futuristic question because emacs has
been around forever
do you think in 100 years
we will still have emacs and vim
or like
pick it pick a let's say 50 100 years
yeah yeah yeah no i mean whenever you're
doing anything in linux
you
you're spending a lot of time editing
little config files and
scripts and stuff and uh you need to be
able to pop in and out of
of editing those things and it needs to
work
like even if the the windowing
gui is dead
and all you've got is like a command
line you to get out of that problem you
might need to to enter an editor
and uh and alter a file so i think on
that level
there will always have to be
sort of uh
very simple well emacs isn't very simple
but you know what i mean there have to
be basic editors that you can use
from either the command line or a gui
just for administering systems
now how widespread they'll be um
you know
there's a certain amount of um what's
the story of the
the there's the the american folk tale
of the
the
the guy who the hammer guy who drives
the railroad spikes john henry
trying to keep up with the steam hammer
and eventually this the steam hammer
wins
because he can't drive the spikes fast
enough so there's there's a sense in
which
you know microsoft like
who knows how much they've invested in
code
you know visual studio
to to you know or apple with xcode so
they've put huge amounts of money into
enhancing
their ides
and emacs in theory can duplicate
all of those features
um
by you know
if you just have enough linux hackers
writing emacs lisp macros
um
but you know
at some point um
it's gonna be hard to
to maintain that
level of uh
to to keep up feature for feature
the the interesting thing about emacs
just is lasted a long time yeah and i i
think if you talked about that
there's a certain like there's certain
fads
certainly
in the
software engineering space
and it's interesting to think about
technologies that sort of last
for a very long time
and just kind of being in the
what is it how do they get by it's like
the the
uh
the cockroaches of software yeah the
bacteria are soft or something they like
this base thing that nobody everybody's
just became reliant on
uh
and they just outlast everything else
and slowly slowly adjust with the times
with a little bit of a delay with a
little bit of customization by
individuals kind of that
but they're always there in the shadows
yeah and they outlast everybody else
and i wonder if that's
that might be the story for a lot of
technologies especially in the software
space yeah shell scripts you know all
that stuff you you can't run the modern
world without
a bunch of shell scripts
you know booting out machines and
and running things so um
it's
that is going to be a hard thing to to
replace
and then tech for type setting that you
use you said
for when when i want to print it out
yeah i just have some simple uh
macros that i use but then i have to um
the publisher put their foot down and
they they want it in in word
format now so
um
years ago i wrote some macros to convert
and this time
what did i do
copy paste
no i um i use of regular expressions so
i was
to do italics in
you know you you put it in curly
brackets and you do backslash i t
and then you type what you want to type
and that's how you get italics in tech
so
you can create a regular expression
that'll look for some text between curly
brackets preceded by
backslash i.t and then uh instead uh
convert that to italics and word will do
that
um
word if you go deep enough into its
search and replace
ui you can do regular expressions is
just reg apps
yeah it's funny that you did that yeah i
mean i'm sure there's tools that help
you with that kind of thing but but the
task is sufficiently
simple
to where you can do a much better job
than anyone anybody else's tool can yeah
yeah so that's a fascinating process it
works fine for me yeah
and it keeps you from messing around
with formatting
yeah like oh what if i put this chapter
heading you know in
you know a sans-serif font yeah it's a
it's just classic wanking
um and so
those options are closed off in what i'm
doing
you